how's it going everybody its Lorne
welcome back to my channel where we talk
about all things Marvel and of course
the MCU today we have some very exciting
news as John Krasinski has met with
Marvel Studios about an upcoming project
now of course as mostly everybody knows
by now pretty much all of the fandom
wants John Krasinski to play mr.
fantastic of the Fantastic Four Reed
Richards and they want his wife Emily
Blunt in real life to play Sue Storm The
Invisible Woman of the Fantastic Four as
well and although both of them have
played pretty coy about any type of
involvement with Marvel Studios we have
reports that both of them have now met
with Marvel Studios about upcoming
projects and John Krasinski himself even
teased the Fantastic Four in one of his
latest YouTube episodes and a personal
source of mine has told me that he is
checked with some of his people and it
seems like John Krasinski as mr.
fantastic is almost a sure thing
however there is more to the story than
just John Krasinski possibly playing a
character in the MCU and we're going to
dive into every single thing that you
need to know about this report and about
what's happening with John Krasinski and
Emily Blunt if you're new be sure to
subscribe to stay up to date on all
Marvel content and so you can enter my
giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox one
or ps4 and picking a winner at 550,000
subscribers so right now for the most
part Marvel Studios is pretty much
closed seeing as how most of their
projects have been put on hold due to
the corona virus but apparently they are
not completely closed as it has been
reported that John Krasinski has met
with some people at marvel studios via
zoom meeting and this could mean a whole
lot for the future of the MCU and there
are five things that you need to know
about John Krasinski and Emily Blunt
possibly taking on the roles of mr.
fantastic and The Invisible Woman and
possibly directing a very big future
Marvel Studios film and number one is
this report that comes from the geeks
worldwide
the report says Marvel hasn't shut down
completely due to the pandemic the
studio has been taking virtual meetings
with various actors writers and
directors over the past weeks and one of
those people is none other than John
Krasinski now on the surface this could
mean a whole slew of things John
Krasinski has stated before that
would like to work with Marvel Studios
and Kevin Feige and Kevin Feige has
stated that he would like to work with
John Krasinski in a recent interview
John stated that he would love to work
with Marvel he said I would love to do
it I think to be a part of the Marvel
world would be amazing anyway and the
fact that people would even consider me
for that level of a part would be
amazing now at the time that he stated
this he had not had any conversations
with Marvel Studios at least that we
know of but now according to this report
he has and this comes at a very very
interesting time and that is because of
the second thing that you need to know
about John Krasinski possibly playing
mr. fantastic and that is that he
actually has teased this and he did it
on Sunday for those of you who may not
know John Krasinski during this pandemic
has recently started a YouTube channel
the channel has been a pretty big
success and the purpose of the channel
was to spread positivity during these
trying times and in his episode on
Sunday he teased plain a comic-book hero
and finally there's this for panel er
which I have to appreciate and it'll be
the closest I ever get to playing a
comic book hero now of course he's
talking about fan art of him obviously
there is a ton of fan art of him as a
mr. fantastic and he teases this when he
puts the emphasis on the four panel and
then of course immediately after he says
that's the closest he'll get to playing
a comic superhero but he immediately
gives us a very interesting look now
clearly if he was in talks to play mr.
fantastic or any other Marvel character
he would not be able to say but that
look definitely implies that he's up to
something and then we get the report a
day later that he's met with Marvel
Studios and this is more than just a
coincidence especially if you consider
the third thing that you need to know
which is that his wife Emily Blunt has
also met with Marvel Studios about a
role in the MCU it was revealed that
while Emily Blunt was filming Jungle
Cruise her movie coming out with the
rock also a Disney movie which Disney
owns Marvel she met with Marvel Studios
now we don't really know much about
anything that happened
this meeting besides the fact that it
was to talk about an upcoming project
that Marvel Studios was working on but
that now means that Marvel Studios has
met with both Emily Blunt and her
husband John Krasinski and there's no
doubt that Marvel Studios knows that the
fans want John Krasinski and Emily Blunt
to play mr. fantastic and The Invisible
Woman and it's very clear by John
Krasinski's YouTube video plus
interviews that he's done that he knows
fans want him to play that as well and
that brings us to the fourth thing that
you need to know that comes from a
report from Mikey Sutton and this is
what Mikey had to say even though
countless fans have been blowing up
social media to have John Krasinski in
the role that doesn't mean that the
studios will listen
however several insiders have told Mikey
such and that Krasinski is in serious
negotiations for mr. fantastic as for
his wife Emily Blunt who would make the
perfect Invisible Woman that is still up
in the air as she apparently isn't
interested in what a lengthy contract
would be however sources have told Mikey
that if Krasinski is cast as mr.
fantastic it's pretty much a sure thing
that blunt will come with him to play
The Invisible Woman and apparently
Marvel Studios is interested in
Krasinski beyond his acting abilities
and are actually looking at him to
direct a Marvel Studios film which we'll
talk about in number five number four is
that the timing of all of this seems to
really line up we recently found out
that Marvel Studios was planning for the
new MCU Fantastic Four to make their
debut in ant-man 3 along with this Paul
Rudd also wrote an entire script that
included modock in it apparently now
Marvel has moved away from this idea and
are thinking about including the young
Avengers in the film but they were
planning on introducing the Fantastic
Four but instead of them actually having
a pretty major role in the movie they'll
probably now be teased in the film which
means we can probably expect an actual
Fantastic Four movie to come out right
around then if not too long after and
Marvel Studios does have a tendency to
pick actors for roles before actual
scripts are done and before directors
are chosen for example they cast Maher
shala alleyway before anything for blade
has been done including script or
casting no directors no writers no one
but Maher Sheila Ali has been cast for
that film the same thing happened with
Captain Marvel they cast brie Larson way
before they had a director and Kevin
you did mention about blade when asked
why blade why now he said because of my
Hershel ollie
so perhaps John Krasinski and Emily
Blunt are just the perfect cast for mr.
fantastic and The Invisible Woman that
they fit so perfectly for the movie to
come out however the last thing you need
to know coming in at number 5 is that
John Krasinski could very well be
directing a Marvel Studios film yes
everybody wants John Krasinski and Emily
Blunt to play mr. fantastic and The
Invisible Woman
of course Marvel Studios knows this and
of course they'll take this into
consideration but just because they may
cast them as characters in the MCU
doesn't mean that they can't also have
John Krasinski direct an MCU film John
Krasinski has recently gotten into
directing and he said that he would be
up for directing a Marvel Studios film
and that brings us to the second half of
Mikey's report and he says that Marvel
Studios is apparently interested in John
Krasinski beyond his acting abilities
they are considering him to direct and
also possibly write the Fantastic Four
movie however that's not all
apparently there was talk about
Krasinski being considered too direct to
additional Marvel Studios films the
midnight sun's movie which would have a
new MCU take on Ghost Rider if blade is
a hit and the next Captain America movie
although it's unknown who will carry the
shield as of right now however
everything is extremely early right now
and they're simply gauging John
Krasinski's interests and directing
future Marvel movies but as far as mr.
fantastic ghosts they are focused on
getting John Krasinski nailed down for
the role of Reed Richards aka mr.
fantastic for his Fantastic Four debut
which we have word could be before the
actual Fantastic Four team debuts as
reported before Marvel Studios
apparently wants the Illuminati to
appear in Doctor Strange and the
multiverse of madness and if you're not
aware of who the Illuminati are they're
a group consisting of the sorcerer
supreme and Doctor Strange Black Bolt
the king of the Inhumans Charles Xavier
the founder of the x-men of course Namor
the Submariner the king of Atlantis
Ironman himself and of course mr.
fantastic of the Fantastic Four now
obviously there's going to be a
different iteration of this considering
that we no longer have Iron Man in the
Marvel
Cinematic Universe but with the
Fantastic Four coming into the MCU not
too long from now and Krasinski be an ID
for mr. fantastic it would make sense
that he would appear in the illuminati
and then from there go on to be a mentor
to spider-man let's not forget the big
building that went up during spider-man
far from home there's a lot of
speculation that it could be the Oscorp
building but Marvel Studios and Disney
themselves don't have the rights to
Norman Osborn but they do have the
rights now to the Fantastic Four so it
would make more sense that this is going
to be the Baxter building whatever the
future holds the Fantastic Four are
definitely coming to the MC of Kevin
Feige himself has mentioned this at San
Diego comic-con of 2019 and it's
appearing as if fans may get what they
want with John Krasinski plane mr.
fantastic and it really does seem like
John Krasinski could have teased this on
his YouTube channel as well and if he
comes then it's more than likely his
wife Emily Blunt will come as the
Invisible Woman but let me know what you
think about all of this new information
that we got today leave a like if you'd
like John Krasinski to play mr.
fantastic of the Fantastic Four
also don't forget to subscribe to stay
up-to-date on everything relating to the
Fantastic Four and all things Marvel as
always thank you all so much for
watching
woof woof